I'm going to see your boss at happy diego walter
payton engineer working with big day
time machine learning internship
virtual angel that is not full of heat he did
in his improvised way you have to cover 20
in what
ok thanks for way
sunday after land
I come to that in what  on the way
ok data center for lazy people
us airways al starbucks min
in general
in 9 in pack working marbella capi and
full city index of spain were here in
the way
my interests ok
picture in the executive program o pete
delta ind school
industrial organization datisa business  school in
spain
announcing you are enthusiastic softworks
teachers without peace
there is no mind free time younger
are ways to contact
the star dust maker
esper and lazy sleeper round thirty euros
a the wing drew end of chicanos the lip
to encourage and shake little a king of
photo anja contini sleeping with amazing
and my next life the one to be eligible is
the perfect definition definition of
place and racing
racing with the following the  oxford
dictionary is willing to work origins
energy
distal titleist datas james forley yep and
for me yesterday
not for
17.25 bad place in the meaning a light
of day' admin in a willing to work for
you sergi in repetitive what a good ear
of seymour both times danger  boys y
mujer terminamos you can do it better
automatic stop and then imagine the
voice with my face skate
cut face the quiet scary
[Music]
ok that is the normal workflow that will
follow when we do that modeling
del robo eta de windows de data cleaning
de fitur selection fitur pre processing
future
[Music]
construction of windows mobile
bioptima and 6 d to put this they will move
dick and then we pallor of model and the
ok we know that the data cleaning of
pence where diet they are and they are city
canopy automatic back
and  I would shoot
and they are finde and winston
we know that we can hudson parts they are
processes they are voting titles they are way
of construcc for world and modern
family they are for optimization and we
k  now that sometimes with the things
underwear to avoid in that is the
automatic machine
mazzini
back
are we are hard wing bands
interesting things
and i'm going to speak about the first
bank and that type
guys and sap iphones a more
automatic car great and mail  marketing
pipelines using genetic program and help
to erase
and the author of that is great don't
you know him but
gb for the interest times tan
anxo tweets about recommended him and also
contributing from in the open source
[Music]
opensource of course
lets si  de más importa palate
we want to optimize machine learning
pipelines and one and we want to be
using genetic program showmatch in
learning pipelines unit case shiller
pipelines young wise men from the secret
pipeline
white plains and siat
just episode end of the wing normal edition
of the cold ouija  the fair fitur the
extractor I am going to apply the
extract filter on the data the data platform
of 30 in this set and when the
wind and it transforms  e data set we apply de
sting the model in that way no so that
thing camby transform you
data dolphin
that is exalead y same but we did find a
way transform data and then apply
mobile
ok show sims is similar but it's very
powerful because it's on  planet we can
change program thriller show that file
than that can contains preprocedural
features selectors models we can
optimize we can't win in son
programmatic way son
we can do something is to try to get the
best pack pipeline ok
me a few years ago son  Current titles
like that are processors or
classify returns and the good thing
it's prince and you can see here we have
the excessive
yes you can also be sexy boxing of
pipelines so we are going to optimize
after even algorithms of we have x
for mobile and  no and we are familia de
siegel i'm so is going to be missing ok
so we want optimistic timelines and how
we want to tweet we want to do it with
genetic programa 'jovenes you know what
is genetic p  program
and it is perfect just in case of sound
using the genetic programming is that
i'm going to the week exploration of the
past ix hubble of people program
that's many photos and play the
steinberg
the depth of going on tour with the
jonas and we know  that of data because
in africa you can find won 3 date for
three and also of predators or if you have
a high position you can see order
small likely to survive and play all
animals in indap case lake on tour bad
white on fiscal tour is  say historical
touring mutation and crossover crossover
is with that one year of which alone
need another tour dejadas con lex y de
jafa chain the next tours will have the
best thing show will probable will
inherit the best part of the left eye
and ear pit ok so  the wind tweetdeck
cross over huermur likely to have to
give back then howick you wish the first
giraffe whitlow neck effects and the wild
on net was because of a nation pencil s
con operation
chapter
reproduces the  other ones software
distribution we can splenda r
happ of evolution in that way ok
soft güicán apply comes out of the same bad
beat pipelines imagine that actress la
pipeline to denis a turin
that we can score
soy may in the wire scoring the trees
software are 3 light that  tri imagine
that a stop fruit equality have shake
score we choose saving
brandon 3 imagine that we can have a lot
of the filter be these processes models
to put
anxo are of combination or friend is just
so random one
uy skorik comes with take the best one
to do a crossover that means we take
some things from the front one parent
and with the others in from the other
parent and we generate useful the dust
children's heart dispar from one parent
data from the forum data from the garden ok already
created sober and the mutation  is with pica
james wan blanca
and then we make sure if we have been
lucky in we have a something better than
before it with that one time and again
and again advenir we are go  ing to find
in which way of weight the actions of
optimal insolation that we want to have
it in that case
that's something
you want to play with you have to have
something the issuer does not basic by
genetics to the game
you can see the genetic walker  y sunny
tour when you can change the genetic
measurement rate you can't center crossover
reid grand saint son fin sans son y
it's going learning to work no isaac
a boxes de ladino morles hot world dp
nicodemus the arts and soft
y es fourth  and no tics in it he recommended
youtube play del wii fit
yo les star with people
that's the way we want optimization with
type t gwynn por from type and then we
already six news to you for classifying
fit
this big data set we don't have to  do
anything oli with that it's going to
start to try pipelines using the genetic
foresees program and when it for you stop
de tv videos probable carry
tried to wait
edwin review de psp line in and out of
the land of the soul you can you see i  t
to predict you can you see you can do
type 2 predict and it will work if you
can you without borders mine in that way
I specific de deitac specified de where
do you want to store the best
pipeline
I have in mind finish you will get  in
that fire the best-paid line
or you can do it in the way you
slater ok vote for minds that will we
can you hear you have annual real with a
table where you can see all the para
merse de default ones
in the best way  to say to see what is
what we can we can you hear there is encore
youtube change the number of generation
population says that will impact english
in the time that is going to
tupí train plains of course as many
generation in population 6 is more like
that you  are going to find the best
buy blake
you can without james fowler fins the
press population design 6 and you don't
know what are you doing you don't know
what do you want to do he recommended to
leave this parameter default
what the important in to change from
scoring of scoring function yuca news
are different from priests and ministers
[Music]
ready the proverb are news corp function
on the changes has been the error of
yuca news your own score childhood
of important of civil of folk of you
want to appling of crossover  validation
because you want to find you don't want
to have over feet and they are normal
and they know
about eudel important change probable this
disc pnv conflict and deep is the way
that your heart to say i want you to try
disalvo lynch i want you to  try this pre
processors i want you to train that
models wind that way you are not just
trying everything you are strange what
you want to drive
so you can you soon default deputy
string light y pot light enthusiasm
radius number of
the process not only for you  by default and
savic said that progress in off to
choose an optimal optimal party line
ándate sois looks con fidel y es just'
work sometimes with the grifters and songs
in similar to that only day 6
okay i  want you to you see that
funkshion andasol of parameters and want
you to train your kids félix ok to
put wang yu tu trajectory force one
you to try that all is of numbers i
want you to try and keep the same no
ok soft leds and  up so sunport that
is
of base that I have always been able to find and
documentation you can see amy of the number
pi generations and population 6 I are
verbo city by having of the ride
outputs
ay the fine of number of youth tumini
one that means to all the  course of my
laptop they
only have you are going to 6 11 letters
are progressive you see is going girona in
ethernet and nine doing
an ha tinh you have the south world
meets ok
from country model line facts
ansa aitor you be for you can sport in
that way type 2 export that we are the
name of love and of the fight that will
create son
civilidad datisa python script dating theory we
take the city file and we will i predict
d
we lost in that sport style and that's
just to take you want  to persie the o  ne
normal models of you can ram age
several time and this is going to big
band on the outcome be of
inferior difference using the same parameters
you can you can say o kate fin that's
the way blind goodenough suenen to
persist you can't sporting gateway  and
yázpik that by jong wook
ok that there is wanted to drive
titanic kagel competition and its position
to bogotá competitions the basic wanning
on cable
you can't fanning of type from the
repository to titán and the sample is not
that that i want is yours
you are from  youssef types we sought anydata
clinic of course of data cleaning are
imported to daemon clean your data more
likely to find the resolution is it so
you can see guide in 20 data clinic alias
gift of speech in kolding of the olympic
savers string collins and for
sad  heart attack
it's not something good so you can see
is willing willie but data clinic show
brian southall
torre
types back and fire fit that's data &
games with publication 6 fifty verbs
city of tw  or about haiti nation
population safe fight and they only have we
will have says sport pipeline
you say for having in project room it
again' you are going to have power
different one change
is fine and 3 for 0 of the fluid
cloud in that to to the titanic al
competition and tap
but the eitc has to know fitting bar
is in the first cause submit in the
titans and competition
estulín scholes guys bid ciro data
cleaning with del jazz try to turn to si
son tirando and we get in the first to
fall of seven fawzan  they are without their end of
being need to dust grade
and something that will we can used to be
are people about 4 we can do what they
died to ok
haydee de sal and they say it brings you back
from house price or from the competition
is to leave  ceim but that time en la
sierra de save the cold y un tapestry objet
the candle there is no don't want to know the
name of the college
r design and that's important this time
is the question function of directing in
the titanic example in cushing scoring
active  and bad there is no definition of being
a -4 love that is the one that values
and is not in the defiant ones snodin
del son
news soft and function and sons and no
matter
this novelty and fiction reflection and
acting director or funsión you have
to  use the word error in the night they do not
work
because it is that way you are going to try
to minimum expansion helping
specifically win to train to maximum
function it is important
I left ceim on wii fit and due to injury
safety act generations says error
faction de  hard disk pipeline
delicious cold combination progress
only caters was in the first
in nine hundred of thousands oncisa meet
and games cruise lines of code
what the one that is really
so
you can say ok
drink milk and yacht clubs
in that way by default world trade and
out of things we are train i tried the car
you don't know you don't want to try
picos como new art expert you feel and 14
you want to lose no morals it's me
specifically inda diccionalesri ok i want  you
[Music]
ok
but morales you can see what is where
i'm in the same ok this to
fix it and i want you just want you to you
sexy post
closing force crisis yesterday in texas and
look for wasipi want you tube just one  of
frame orius a commission of windows
parameters late because to put pressure
spacey faison processes features elector
with the parameters and want to try
softline because you can used in all the
stage of your data modeling and you'll
see the first to know what is the  best
approach
julius
linear models tressor what i want to be
ok
you can do a data cleaning processing
and drive only mobile phones and i wish you
at least son height son gente a but what
is what you have to be or you know it's
only the mother  but you don't know it's
yorwin parameters of yours
that is something like news from the
grifters by insight for that you can do
it in a kléber way i used in that ford
win in a djanet program in way
org
you know the modern i want to  do you
want to  try are processes are pins
are it can help you to give you
something to you star when you don't know
what you and i can't help you tube
and 100 of those to get into juventus
optimal is that and that I considered like that
has aliancista is not the link
light is something essential age airbnb and
blog post recommended
wait important because they say that
the news the automatic machine learning
for improve the way update de data
saints
de giucich as in the ways
aitor in for giving son hinds audita  and
four
org get the best to get involved there
are five more and orio
the slide
diaries uy
jupiter notebook are
Mr. exam by goodison explanation
rafa body that is the guitar rest in
cream
[Applause]
but question
in decision to put willis to priests and
obtain from  jupiter five
of course and something that helps but
it's going to read more time bag of
population they care because it if
you know progression crisis side
you can reduction hunger or erase and
we are rich  probable your are going to
train more things but you want the
genetic program work for you know you
want from the
orión show edition of type of the time you
have that are basic they are for their five
affecting by the fall sarwan andreone
andrés guaje one hundred with training
day at the races evil sets and saturday 30
words social age your bag and without that
laptop and without hatred in favor of the hardware
pro list is going to be there for you
anyway rafa progress
white switch
will give you you must lose the stop of
optimizing is  not going to you are not
going to lose d
efe even you can you so to put and
that i sing the end to put in de
type of warnes start that means
that you can't just the finding xin wang
great interest want you  can yus from that law
of say me yet for one for the
generations to walk and it's going to help
the top team is the show you can have the
rolling of the over fitting show
pixar's arduino pipeline linda tell dadt set
okay ucanews cross valid  ation but we are
doing media optimization song
there are notes that you can't have are
university
and the second wind is combining in
sampling model i30 separating them
and path combined prinze jr
you can see it using a rip civil
reed hasting net the repressor press
solís using  of booty classified
please with Méndez
Félix wing trade show imagine of hits
by the possible number of for that is one
way we want you just wright brown and or
so we want you to specify you see with
fidel you can be your song knowledge
that of pro  bands in new voice of dita
and you can specific
because I know
the question is the way 6,500 close and
work to make a type of uses of ming for
the court or what type of volume zinc or
what are you from moment you can't you se  for
the station index machine type test
using
let us type of that deep ford diane team
program from news corp news scope
from pizza distribute from distributors from
evolution r something horrible to see
inside and will be possible but it's no  t
possible a at the moon and software
interested in the wind that we can
contribute that law
collector questions thank you for
investing top have problems